part of what I do is work with people
who are preparing to be part teachers
k12 our teachers work with artists I've
taught studio based courses and ceramics
drawing and also working with grad
students who are interested in engaging
and research about and through and
within art practices visual culture
practices so there's this range of folks
so what if you're what I'm trying to
negotiate a place to enter it Larry one
of the things that you said was somehow
explicit yeah am i with you know this as
we've been calling it this hidden agenda
right curriculum is gender nobody's the
same thing right in many cases it's the
same thing right because you have an
agenda that you're trying to cover
whether it's an official agenda we can
correlate that to the official
curriculum and I'm pulling that this
term correctly these curriculum pieces
from the work of George Posner and
others right where you might consider
their five kinds of curriculum that are
happening at the same time five
concurrent curricula he says there's the
official curriculum which is what it's
written down is that officially mandated
this is what will be taught then there's
the operational curriculum it's what you
put into practice tank operationalize it
okay so you could be the official agenda
than the operationalized agenda so
agenda and curriculum to me agenda gets
a bad rap just like propaganda but
that's a different kettle of horses okay
so then the third curriculum that Posner
talks about is the hidden curriculum
what is not official what is not
officially written down and intended and
what also is not necessarily
operationalized intentionally but it is
what is hidden and gets learned and
taught at the same time the fourth would
then be the null curriculum what is not
taught but is not intended to be
it's absent and explicitly missing and
then the fifth is the extra curriculum
that doesn't happen inside those
intentional spaces though it might think
as formalized schooling so if we think
of you know you're on the volleyball
team that's extra curricular but it's
still related to that education space
all five of those things are happening
all the time so the hidden agenda
they're hidden curriculum is one that I
and there's some tension there right
because in some cases it's
operationalized with a conscious
awareness that it's hidden I'm not going
to be explicit about it but then there
can be a hidden curriculum where it's
being taught and learned without the
intention of it being taught and learned
cutes - for example there are bathrooms
bathrooms boys and girls and so it's
teaching us certain things about how
society is structured but when we move
and have a shift in our cultural and
social space where bathrooms don't have
to have certain labels then other
knowledge other ideas are taught and
learned through those gestures but
they're not necessarily official does
that make sense yeah okay so the program
where I teach at Penn State for in our
education also at V CFA we're very
explicit about what that hidden agenda
might be as to the point where it's not
hidden at all it's very up front it's
very official and it gets operationalize
in terms of focus on social justice a
focus on the the role of artists and art
in the world
and-and-and what matters matter and how
we can engage with concepts like such as
in theories like we heard in the
introduction feminist theory or a
critical race theory or a critical
pedagogy or we can think about
anti-racist theory right so we can think
about what disability studies all of
these different ways in which society
operates are part of the curriculum that
I've been part of in these two
institutions to look at the preparation
of teachers so someone who says hey I
want to go you know study in this
program it's not a surprise to them when
we start
talking about feminist pedagogy and
feminist issues what might be a surprise
is perhaps the ways in which we approach
that and then operationalize it but it's
not it shouldn't be a surprise now in
some cases some people might not always
read the the fine print but and then
there might be a surprise there but I'm
not I don't I don't hide those issues as
a matter of fact I'm very upfront with
with my undergraduates about you know in
this course we're going to we're going
to learn about learning and I'm more
interested in learning than I am in
teaching and that doesn't make sense to
a lot of people who are preparing to be
teachers or thinking about teaching
because to frame it around learning
suggests there's a shift from the agency
of the teacher as the primary vehicle to
the to the student do I need a first
course where there's no interference
with learning to draw Basics in a basic
way and then after that I can come to a
second level drawing class where you can
lay on all this other stuff or from the
very beginning in even the most
rudimentary learning of the medium are
you already insinuating into the design
of this curriculum this other set of
concerns I don't even I don't have to
know anything about the basics
independent of this second concern to
start learning this other set of things
no one can enter with the concerns and
that is your plan most of the time all
of that all the time oh that's so we
start with we start with that's a social
social issue or let's say we're
grounding the the course within a social
space right we all live in a social
space we all come with the set of
concerns we all come with a set of
experiences we come to the studio and
then return to wherever we were before
that what what what we experience
outside of the studio is content for art
making its content for
engagement through art so you know this
this is a this is a shift where we think
of you know so if we take a step back to
notions of curriculum a very basic a
very basic question in curriculum design
curriculum theory curriculum development
I should say is what is worth knowing
what content do we want students to
learn what is worth knowing you know we
might then look through the progression
of curricula and then folks 30 40 years
ago ship make start making a shift our
thing what is worthwhile what matters
and what is happens is there's a
movement away from a more modernist
notion of art as material based to art
as a reflection and engagement within
the world
not that it hadn't been that way before
but that the the world becomes art
making medium and in a context that can
be not only reflected and depicted but
can also be used as one of the materials
within art making practice and that art
practice can have some sort of engaged
in an intentional effect within there so
what so the kind of drawing class that
you're mentioning or describing it's not
uncommon these kinds of courses happen
quite often but their titles don't
always reflect that and in the lot and
many art schools are ship making some
shifts I've mentioned to a colleague a
number of years ago I said you know we
really need to change the names of some
of these courses like we should have you
know art with Larry know you know art
505 art with Larry and then art 507 art
with Steve and they would have a sense
of what that course was about it's not a
materials specific course although it
could be but when we move the focus to
issues ideas concerns engagements
problems ideas that that is an easier
entry point for the kinds of pedagogy
that we're talking about that that that
lend themselves to the sensibilities of
disruptive
corrupted practices of social
consciousness of transformative learning
and what I've taken from your comments
on occasion is that I ought to have that
objective if I'm if I'm gonna teach
people about operating their community
don't just teach the method or the
content but get to this other level and
build that into the curriculum take
responsibility for that be explicit
about it be accountable not just during
but you've before although who knows
whether they would have let me anywhere
near the place if I had said at the
beginning our goal here is to bring
about change in this community well it
depends on your strategy there right so
if you think about it this way not and
not in you didn't mention this in your
your story but I'm I would be interested
in this component because it also then
gets back to part of one of those parts
of the longer question you asked me
earlier about my own students my own
teaching this is part of the social
studies curriculum officially right
there should be some objectives there
should be some state standards or
district standards or district
objectives that many teachers consider
to be the curriculum and they teach to
those standards or to those objectives I
teach my students put those aside let's
build on what you know what is most
important what you know but on your own
politics build on the let's start with
the themes and the ideas and the
concerns that you have build your
curriculum around that drawing on your
art practice your knowledge of art and
then let's compare let's use those
standards or those objectives as an
assessment now how many of those did we
address usually we can cover all of
those but if we start the other way
around we start with you know learning
objective six and learning objective
eight and this is the lesson it's gonna
be really narrow and tight and it does
and you're always going to be interested
in we got to kick it back into the
center we got to make sure there but in
the way that you did it I would imagine
you could have said at any given moment
when you felt some resistance well if we
look at this
we're covering XYZ one two three four
five six seven because and this is a way
that one not trying to say this is how
you do a cover-up story but this is how
you can justify this a this the social
practice social engagement social
consciousness pedagogy is you say look
we're meeting all of the standards as a
matter of fact if we were to do let's
say three units like this over the
course of the year we could hit all of
those objectives each time if we do it
in a more conventional approach we might
only address one of those objectives
once or a few of them very superficially
so this becomes an even more potent way
to make to make a case because you're
using the you're talking about values
the objectives against them yes I call
it playing judo you use your opponent's
strength and speed to your advantage
right yeah you know when I teach
graduate students who are in a
professional degree program all of this
has easily talked about its layered into
the the social objectives the social
change in fact the that it's all easily
included in the conversation and there's
an explicit reflection on the social
impact social implication social change
or who gets who wins who loses if you do
this and so on it's just it's
fascinating to me that you're teaching
teachers are teaching kids in elementary
school and you're in a sense teaching
the same thing and you're not really
modulating that much you're still saying
as biases here you do everyone has a
bias learn what you're including what
you're not including and it sounds like
you would say that to every level and
did the teachers teaching in every level
and that was it was surprising to me
that all of this was as explicit in your
curriculum in your teaching for K
through 12 as it is in teaching
professionals a couple examples to them
to say yes to support what you're saying
so
you know their number of course is that
that one might find in an undergraduate
or pre-service or an education
curriculum right you can imagine there's
this has to be a 101 or what we know
aren't education 101 right intro and
then there has to be the student
teaching at the other end and and
somewhere in there there's a practical
course many places have methods courses
there's a usually a history course or a
cultural practices or cultural
foundations course and there's also a
curriculum course and it depends on what
institution where I'm teaching but
usually if it's the curriculum course or
the the cultural and social foundations
course the first day of class this is
how I start the class now you we've
known each other for almost two years
now and and we've sat through these
conversations so you know what I look
like you know what I sound like
but imagine students who are just
showing up to class for the first time
right and this is how I start the class
good afternoon my name is dr. carpenter
and I'll be your instructor this
semester so for the next 16 weeks we'll
be engaging in curriculum and cultural
and social issues related to arts
education now some of you come to the
course as artists and others come as and
I continue in just this way and we start
to read the syllabus and at a certain
point I just can't do this or I cannot
find different regions of the UK to move
around my accent you know and certain
students start to see and look and then
I say well now the next thing that we're
going to do and I changed my voice like
this and I stopped them right there does
the first day class Larry you're you
haven't blinked in a minute and your
mouth is wide open and you're giggling
and what's going on here and and I make
them toxic well what's up well you sound
different I sound different than what
well you sound different than you did
before what did I sound like before well
you sounded had an accent oh I did what
kind of accent well they said well you
know if I'm someplace else I have an
accent there but when I'm home I don't
have an accent people who sounded like
that at home don't have an accent it's
only when they leave and so what else is
different and they and they
also in talking about well we moved them
to the space to say faces that look like
mine in most people's conception at
least in institutions where I teach
don't sound like that or the conception
of someone with an accent like that
looks different than I do so but I put
it on the table and I draw attention to
what this pigmentation looks like and
and what it sounds like to talk like
this you know or if I talk like this or
I haven't so the idea of how accents
inform and influence biases that's it
day one I say so how do you sound when
you talk to your students how does your
your language how does the way you dress
speak to your students and also how do
you respond to your students based on
what they sound like and what they day
one and you wouldn't be you that's not
keyed to the age or level of the so this
becomes part of what it means to be a
teacher we so if you're interested in
teaching learners you have multiple
identity from that space but if you're
gonna assume that all learners are
learners or learners learners it's much
easier you just kind of deliver stuff
and expect it to come back in the same
way it's not messy at all for the for
the younger ones so I've I'm also
spending the year this year as an artist
and learner in residence at an
elementary school in my town so I visit
the first grader the class of first
graders just about every Friday and then
I'm working with the entire third grade
team no that's okay
yeah well it's funny you say that
because one of the things I'm doing I do
with I've been doing with the 3rd
graders is looking at the water crisis
and I know several of you some of you
are interested in the water crisis
global water crisis so in third grade
Africa is their social one of their
social studies units it worked out
really quite well in connection with the
African Diaspora water curriculum that
I've been working on that was funded by
the African a Research Center and stayed
and so we talked about so to talk to
them about the water crisis in Africa if
there's a moment in which for some
learners and for some teachers there
could be in a moment where you equate
Africa no water all Africans have no
water right I have to call that out
there's also a moment where and this
happens beyond third-grade where it
happens in the news happens in TV shows
it happens in textbooks it happens in
daily conversation where people will say
I'm going on a trip multiple places I'm
going to fly to France and I'm gonna go
to Germany and I'm gonna go to Africa
really you're gonna go to a country
country continent where we frame Africa
as an entire country and for those third
graders to learn that to learn what I
mean by that to learn that Africa is a
country know Africa is one continent
made of multiple countries somehow that
doesn't always happen these think it's
and so the the the message then in
society is one that needs to be attended
to right I mean it certainly then lends
itself to two biases or
misunderstandings about about the
continent so I make it clear that I made
quite a third-grader so but this is how
I do it so and I put a map of Africa I
would say so here's the country of
Africa and we're gonna talk no what do
you mean it's not with a little bit of
joking with a little teasing to make
sure and I may enable them and allow
them to make explicit what their what
they're hearing and to continue to do
that is quite important Walter Bateman
there's a book by walter Bateman he
wrote I think after he retired from
College of Education he was at
university Minnesota it's called
teaching through inquiry and one of the
strategies that he uses that I borrow or
he writes about in this book is you know
it's it's kind of it's based on the
Socratic method but it's also based in
this notion of inquiry through the
process
asking questions one can reveal but to
make sure students are paying attention
you can you know provide information
that's factual factual not factual
factual and see when and how they pick
up on it and I love doing that with the
younger kids or when it's time to share
so then another component is I've been
sharing with the students challenges
design challenges that are drawn
directly from lack of access to adequate
access to water in different countries
in Africa as exemplified in in you know
from different different places so
whether it's the water filter or pumping
water or piping water or transporting
water or collecting water out of the air
through the moisture so I said look you
know here's an example imagine you live
in a rural town and you have an amazing
access to to water but it's filled with
disease and mosquito larvae and all this
design I'd like you to design a way to
filter that water but you can't use any
electricity you can't use any oil or any
gasps no no no no motive motion or power
other than your human human body
divided into group of two three four and
draw this and I give them ten minutes
maybe eight-year-olds right
eight nine you're up then they go away
and they draw and then when they share
these things this is the same challenge
that you give that designers are dealing
with in the world right now the drawings
are incredible their design the
conversations they're having are
incredible but the way I frame it is
imagine you lived in a town blah blah
blah blah I don't say matter you lived
in this African village and to take it
away from that although although they
are studying Africa I take it away from
that and make it a more generic space
for than to think through then I say
well you know in certain countries in
Africa this is the case just like in
certain states in this country just like
in other countries in the world so I
don't just leave it there making it
explicit with the students is very very
important and they gonna get it I'm
still on this idea that there's this
special quality
about social being a socially disruptive
artist or being a teacher who's trying
to take this into account and it's it
all the other things that we try to help
people get better at teaching or better
at doing something doesn't get at this
core and quality could I think it is
different and special and scary and oh I
think it's yeah I think it's all of
those things I also maybe you recall I
said you know like when I'm doing the
water fountain work I still get anxious
yeah so you don't know all off and
bellies they might do this watching all
these YouTube videos tells me you know
people mr. Buggs all the time but it's
but it's it's the social engagement that
is an important part of the materiality
of that work just like clay is an
important material part of ceramics
obviously and not everybody is as able
and with all media as they would like to
be or teaching and learning certain
content so that's just an understanding
what this is different in kind than
learning another medium
I'm terrible terrible terrible
watercolor but watch me go when I do
something else okay I can get better at
it you can teach me to get better at it
isn't I'm not great at it it I've never
been good at it but okay if I put enough
effort in and you give me coaching and I
try it and I watch it I'll get better I
just have a sense that being ready to
commit to engage in public spaces in
something aimed at changing the way
people think about things who are
challenging their identity is not
something that you can build the
capacity in the same way like so this is
this I want to answer this question
another way because I think we're going
around on this the same question and I
appreciate the provocations so if I
think about the most recent
semester where I taught the
participatory inquiry course a range of
students in this course one student from
I believe she
she's in sociology or comparative
literature perhaps comparative
literature was not about to perform you
know to do the reading in public but it
was very interested in graphic novels
comics visual representation and was all
in the issue she was interested in was
this conversation on campus about
unionizing graduate students right and
so it was kind of concern about how do I
perform unionizing and the political
issues there and and so we talked about
her interest in graphic novels and
comics and what she ended up doing was
essentially it was a survey of sorts
asking people to provide her with
feedback their perspective on this on
this issue on unionization of grad
students and with little drop boxes
where they could you know it's almost
like there's the suggestion boxes right
and she put them in strategic places
collected them and then had made graphic
you know visual representations almost
like cartoon each on these squares
panels and then post with with the the
speech bubbles of the content as the the
cut that was the content from those
suggestions the anonymous suggestions
that people gave her and then she would
post these on bulletin boards so you
could see this public display of
comments she physically put this in the
world but she didn't physically put
herself in the world does that make
sense yes so we're playing to her
strengths that well and that's why the
the particulars of what she was about
when she was interested in which I was
capable that's what that woman this
other another student who was an
architecture was interested in so on our
campus I don't know how it happens
around Cambridge and around MIT but we
have a different representatives from
different religions or different beliefs
who will set up in different parts of
campus and they're allowed to do that
and they'll pass out literature and and
they'll engage people in conversation
and so what this one student did well
he wanted he wanted to emulate their he
want to borrow their their mode their
presentation but not their message he
wanted to actually substitute out their
message of religion and spirituality
with concepts from architecture and so
he exactly so instead so imagine you
walking down the sidewalk and someone
says oh may I talk to you about you know
being saved or may I talk to you about
you know really spiritual enlightenment
or whatever and then instead of doing
that he said you know do you have a
moment because I'd like to talk to you
about the differences between concrete
and cement and their uses in
architectural structures but he's
dressed as it I was like a really a
mighty thing right but he's dressed as
as someone that you might see on campus
in the guise of a spiritual or religious
practice so in that way he felt very
comfortable doing that but it was about
well how do we how do you how do you
take on that persona without my wasn't
trying to trying to use that that visual
as as momentum and so played to his
strengths you play tonight people's
there's a lot of ways of doing this
you're playing to people's strengths
that's what it's about now
you